remember the s.a.t exam man it was a
tough one
it's been around for over 90 years now
this exam was actually an assessment
designed to evaluate students college
specific skills
and while it's very rare to get a
perfect score sally jeremiah found a
ccsd student who was able to accomplish
that for both the s.a.t
and a.c.t i'm ambitious but also
friendly i also like to have
goals and i like to set up things in
advance to help achieve those goals
jang cho is a clark high school junior
he got a perfect score for both the
s.a.t
and act tests for the sat it was a 1600
and for the act it was 36 or i went into
high school i made like a little plan
of what i wanted to do every year of
high school while cho
says distance learning was tough
especially with the lack of social
interaction
he focused on keeping busy in some
aspects online school
allowed me to spend more time on things
i'm passionate about but also
um i challenge myself and like new
endeavors as well
he does have advice for other teens
taking the test rather than like
you know um necessarily like um
spending all of your time trying to like
you know read books it's more kind of
about
learning how to take the test joe and
his friends use free resources
youtube videos and practice tests found
on reddit
me and some of my friends started this
organization called the las vegas
student information hub
we actually set out on this mission to
like you know post
like sat ac ap like articles
uh you know how to start how like we
study for them and how you know we were
able to find success
their goal to help bridge the gap but
cho reminds other students
test scores aren't always um everything
there's so much more to a person than
just
numbers sally caramillo 8 news now
all right so just take a guess once joe
graduates where would you think he'd
want to go if he got a perfect score in
the act
and the s.a.t he wants to go to harvard
and he wants to become a dermatologist
brian
ivy league seems like the obvious choice
when you're getting perfect
i got a perfect score when i took mine
in high school denise for the first
seven questions
about five minutes of the exam i started
kind of having a rough road